قبل ساعات من نهايه العام الجديد تتعرض
كيف اقل من 48 ساعه الى غارات جديده طال
القصف هذه المره مباني سكنيه في منطقه
فيتشرتسكي دمر صاروخ روسي احد الفنادق في
وسط العاصمه كيف حيث قتل شخص جراء شظيه
كما طال القصف منطقه نتيجه شظايا سقطت
لتصيب بعض المباني وتخلف عدد من المصابين
الذين نقلوا الى المشافي لتلقي الرعايه
الصحيه بلغ عدد الضحايا اثنا عشر مصابا
بينهم مواطن في حاله حرجه بحسب السلطات
الدمار هنا حيث واقف طال جميع المباني في
المحيط تحطمت النوافذ الزجاجيه وخلعت
الابواب رئيس مكتب ديوان الرئيس الاوكراني
علق على الهجوم ووصفه من هجوم الارهابي
وقال ان الرؤوس تعمدوا استهداف مناطق
مهوله السكان في عطله اعياد الميلاد وراس
السنه لارهابي الاوكرانيين وكسر عزيمهم
وقد كانت الحكومه في حاله تاهو واقعه هذا
الهجوم كما قال الرئيس الاوكراني زينكي ان
الروس لن يفوت مثل هذه المناسبه دون
محاوله ارهاب المواطنين وتنفيذ ضربات
جديده ويذكر ان السلطات قد الغت جميع
مظاهر الاحتفالات في كييف وجميع المدن
الاخرانيه وشددت على الالتزام بحظر
التجوالي مما يجبر الاخرى لينا على
استقبال العام الجديد في بيوتهم لقناتي
العربيه والحدث حذيفه عادل كيف